[Music]
when I
sleep I see strange
[Music]
things
memories not
Memories new
things
I see
everything that is
not
[Music]
everything
what a wonderful
day
Mr
snow after everything you've seen out
there in the
world what are the Hunger Games for are
you are
you coming to the
tree
The Hunger Games they're to punish the
districts those tributes don't have a
choice Your Role is to turn these
children into spectacles not
survivors we're
live smile it's why we have
teeth imagine it was your name that they
both
strange I just want to know that
somebody still cared about me that I was
still a
value welcome to the capital you look
like you shouldn't be here I shouldn't
but I'm your Mentor a
rebel I am going to get you out of here
you want to protect
people and it's essential to accept what
human beings
are and what it takes to control
them let's see you use that famous snow
charm you seem like a good man Corina
snow I have seen what war does to
people fued with a ter of becoming
prey see how quickly we become
Predator I want my enemies to see a
rainbow of
Destruction engulfing the
world your moners all of
you good luck with that poor little song
bird where is
she
it's mystery and Mysteries have a way of
driving people
mad Mr snow let me ask you one final
time what are the Hunger Games
for a
Hanging
[Music]
Tree
it's the things we love most that
destroy
us
Wild
oh yeah I'm the king of
Atlantis true king builds Bridges
right true king builds
Bridges during King Alan's time there
were Seven Kingdoms and the Trident was
a curse upon them
all the tridon dark magic is spreading
he means to end the bloodline two if you
standing to together as
brothers promise me you will protect
each
other I don't know what lies ahead but
we can't leave our children in a world
without
hope got a bunch of King [__] to do back
ATL go come
on hers it's an oldfashioned Den
notion but the world can still use
them ready whatever it takes whatever it
takes we destroyed
Thanos but it's not over my work is
inevitable there will always be
more to finish
[Music]
it this is just the
beginning she tore a hole in
space there's a different
reality leading into
[Music]
ours
what are you prepared to do I rful your
powers only make me stronger see it
can't be
[Music]
matched can't be
controlled I'm
asking for one last
fight
mon you cannot protect your
people but you can stand all without
standing
alone they're
[Music]
here the marveles r
PG-13 uhoh Monica you got to fly no no
no black girl magic
in Peters Friday get tickets
[Music]
now
fore
I love me
d
give
better
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm telling you it's going to be another
hot one out there in fact there are heat
alerts in effect for New Jersey feeling
like
100°
leaving me here on my
own what is
that
for the first time in New York history
people froze to death in the middle of
July what is it the death
chill the power to kill by fear
itself your veins turn to rivers of ice
your bones crack and the last thing you
see is your own tear GTS freezing
up like literally scared to death so
[Music]
cool
foreign spee
speee
[Music]
foree
spe
for
Fore
[Music]
fore
[Applause]
[Music]
this world is beyond
cruelty you've been fighting the Harkin
for decades my family's been fighting
them for
centuries and they were
massacred alongside my father your
father didn't believe in
Revenge we believe in fman let me fight
beside
you
reload he said that I got
that
thanks I won't be fighting for him I'm
fighting for my
[Music]
people you young
pop you believe in
Paul there are
signs the prophet why is that a bad
thing use
it because of all my Visions lead a
horror because you lose control because
I gain
it Johnny do you believe in
me Paul trades is still
alive deal with this
Prophet show me who you
are
your
father was a weak
man luu's back from the
dead now do what must be
done we gave them something to hope for
that's not
hope I will love you as long as I
breathe
this prophecy is how they enslave
us it's not a prophecy it's a story I
don't care what you believe I
believe I am Paul M Diva
traes Duke of
[Music]
baracus
he who can destroy a thing has the real
control of
[Music]
it when the war
started theyve protected
me took better care of me than humans
would
have they're not people
Maya it's just
programming
10 years ago today the artificial
intelligence created to protect us
detonated a nuclear warhead in Los
Angeles this is a fight for our very
existence Sergeant Taylor we are this
close to winning the
war but the AI are developing a super
weapon retrieve
it or they win to you
[Music]
did you locate the weapon yeah it's just
a
key are you going to heaven no you got
to be a good person to go to heaven then
we're just saying we can't go to heaven
cuz you're not
good and I'm not a
person do you have any idea what that
thing is she looks like a little girl
now but she's
growing Whoever has that kid wins the
war which side you want
huh what do you want sweetie for robots
to be
free oh we don't have that in the fridge
how about ice
cream
dream dream
Dre Dre
Dre
this is
Bella Bella this is Mr mandles hello
[Music]
Bella she's an experiment good evening
her brain and her body are not quite
synchronized but she's progressing at an
accelerated
piece
tell me where did she come from I
shall for it is a happy
[Music]
tale I am Bella Baxter and there is a
world to enjoy circumnavigate it is the
goal of all to progress grow a woman
plotting her course to Freedom how
[Music]
delightful
B
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
my son never show
Mercy they are
pray we are
predators Bo your mother is
dead she died because you sent her away
she was weak sick in her mind you know
my business yes
power is about
strength if you show
weakness you will give our enemies an
opening shoot
shoot he's weak like his mother leave
him what happened that
day I stared death in the face and for
the first time I saw my true
self tell me about this
Hunter they say he uses a connection
with animals to track his
prey once you're on his
list there's only one way off there six
of us and only one of you there's six of
you
[Music]
now
why do you hunt my father puts evil into
the
world I take it
[Music]
out I think you have some kind of Honor
you are exactly like our father just
another man hunting for a
trophy we're
murderers isn't that what he taught
[Music]
us you don't get to do that to me
anymore
Mr
tlan Mr
tlin where's Mr tlin oh you're standing
in
him you're a goddamn lunatic oh you just
figure that out
now there is an animal injan ofas
don't you want to know why they call me
the
[Applause]
rhu
[Music]
ET 5 minutes to the war zone we
must
fire Soldier
[Music]
go
go help
[Music]
me
w
[Music]
what
mother
hello Joe
where let's discuss your new job what
I got a wife she's pregnant please let
me
go at Mard your work consists of pushing
the
mill failure to meet your daily quota
will result in a
punishment the employee with the fewest
points will be
[Applause]
terminated when do I go
home you are well on your your
[Applause]
way oh
[__] you still don't believe the rules
apply to
you perhaps you would respond to other
incentives you took everything from
me what is this you're still asking
questions walk through the door prepare
your mind for a transformative
experience by
malard you're a crucial part of our team
for
life all I needed was a love you
G have you guys taken the test yeah 3
years ago we were positive felt like a
weight have been
lifted I founded this institute to take
the risk out of love no more uncertainty
no more wondering if you've chosen the
right partner no more divorce we were
the first to build the machines to
conduct the test to make the bond of
love
stronger I really want to work
here a lot of famous people study there
really like who Ginger Spice she's my
favorite I
know so you'll be shadowing air he's
already one of our most successful
instructors what's the one thing you
love most about Maria take your time I
love her
hair it's soft it's nice H it's nice
the truth is we're all achingly lonely
and we're endlessly searching for ways
to fill that void I asked you something
why do you work at The Institute maybe
you understand love a little
better I really want to learn how the
exercises help you connect why are we
doing this I thought it'd be fun it's
just messy that's
all I think it's normal to get into a
bit of a routine I think relationship
should be worked on every day oh sorry
sorry I was wondering if it was possible
that one person could be in love with
two people at the same time it's a
biological impossibility yeah that's
what I thought
too I need to tell you
[Music]
something all I
knew Only
You
H expecting anyone I need to have an
intimate understanding of your marriage
the good and the bad I promise it's
confidential is between you and me do
you feel happy here of course I'm happy
here aren't you do you you feel you know
how she would react in every
situation I've always had this fantasy
that there's something else out there
for
[Music]
me do you want to live mundane lives or
do you want to be part of something
special and unique you've been selected
to live up there okay well you're
wasting your time cuz we haven't even
been on an airplane she it I should I
should clarify I'm talking about you
here junior only
[Music]
you we're going to ensure hen has
company while you're
away we're going to replace
[Music]
you I don't want a robot living with my
wife do you really want to leave her
here all alone day after day he doesn't
really see me
anymore maybe I shouldn't be telling you
this
jior I encourage you to use this
opportunity to act on your
instincts whatever we decide we'll be
[Music]
together